okay everybody I'm so excited today
because I am joined by Shan Aston and
Christopher poaha who star in the shift
which comes out now in theaters how you
guys doing today hey brother good we're
how we're well how are you I'm doing
great I'm so pumped to talk to you guys
uh my first question here is for Sean
Sean a lot of comments on the trailer
people are really excited to see you
doing more action in sci-fi so at this
point in your career is there any genre
that you will not do or just not open to
at all oh than porn yeah other than porn
no I mean I you know who go where the go
where the work is you know I I don't
know there's nothing um you know vampire
Thriller sure sure why not uh no I I
like I like doing all you know what I I
really prefer at the moment at this
moment in my life comedic stuff because
life is hard and you know you go and do
movies like this and and they're hard
you know you had it was hard for hard
work you know and I'm just like I think
maybe something that's a little bit a
little bit easier and then the way it's
always gone in my career is just when
you you've enjoyed that a little bit
then you're like I need something really
you know something to really dig into ex
how about a Hallmark movie would you
ever do would you ever do yes absolutely
I got I got I got some for you I just
got a job you guys I got I got some
awesome cool I love that and I love
you're open to all this stuff yeah yeah
Christopher I absolutely love the
narration you do in this film is Kevin
when you were narrating were you
actually seeing the footage of the movie
in front of you and you have any tips
for just doing that narration you know
what's funny that's a great question and
such a such a like smart question bro
because now I don't think a lot of
people would pick up on that stuff
normally the way that things work is
that you would have the luxury of
sitting in a nice big room cans on the
ears watching it and sort of allowing it
to we didn't have the time because this
movie was filmed January February March
and to hit that December 1 release date
they were jamming out this and it was a
fascinating process there was a there
used to be almost a 2hour and 20 minute
version of the film um they went through
a lot of different editing processes and
so once that picture was locked they
threw the narration in after the fact
and they said hey you know what to tie
the story together we're going to add
this element so I went in and I just I
just read stuff and I and I was
listening to myself of course I knew
what scenes they were going to go in so
like I knew when Kevin was praying like
what that was I knew the whole beginning
I knew the end um Brock Heasley uh you
know he's a very particular uh precise
Storyteller he knows what he
wants and again he would ask me to say
something and I'd be like yeah but I
think I'm gonna say it this way be like
yeah I know but can you say it like I
need you to say it the way that it's
written and can you say can you
emphasize that thing and um there is a
bit of just being flexible and saying
you know what I'm going to do it that
way I'll give you that one can you give
me this one um the only thing I was
really particular on was instead of
saying Molly in the beginning of the
narration I said find my way home and I
think that was a good call because then
there's the call back at the end yeah
well I'm just talk about the end of the
movie don't talk about the end don't see
the movie in theaters you know what's
funny with actors sometimes is you you
want to do something over and over again
and I guess when you're when you're
sending in like an audition tape it's
the most where you are in charge of
looking at yourself because you're
deciding what to send in or not and
you're like I want to do it again I want
to do it again I want to do it again and
a certain point like what may seem
complet you know take one and take 30
they seem so different to you to a
person who walks up it's like bro you're
in it you can't not do it if you just
say it it's who you are you're living in
this character for these months of doing
what however long you did the the show
and it's like you know can you just
record this at lunch real quick for us
and you're like yeah but yeah dude do
you did you ever work with a guy named
Jerry LaVine no director used to be an
actor long time ago Teen Wolf Jerry
LaVine anyway I was working on a TV show
with him called life unexpect years ago
I played this character baze and he gave
me this blessing he spoke life into my
life in a way that no other director has
where he was like brother you can't make
a mistake he's like you are B he like
anything you do is baz and to that point
once you're in it once it's your role
you get to have that life of being like
and it really is like yeah let's just do
this thing we're going to do our thing
it's so funny because th this movie is a
see it in the theater movie you know
it's a it's a it's a movie that has the
size of the canvas the the the framing
of the shots is is sort of old school
scope and uh and yet you hear these
intimate words that he saying and so
you're just doing it like you're doing
it on a day but the audience is
experiencing it it's going into
their their whole Spirit
yeah yeah no that's all great is
something that you should see in the
theater if you you know let people know
to go out on December 1st especially if
you like these kind of movies if you
want to see more of them you got to vote
with your dollar and the box office has
to be representative of that but it's
it's unlike anything I've ever seen it's
it's a Sci-Fi weird that it's a
Christmas movie yeah it's a Christmas
movie no it is I mean it's like it's
it's at the beginning of especially if
you see it at the beginning a Christmas
because it's so heavy but it's all about
like the choices you make that lead to
who you are and his family is what he
wants and he's fighting the whole movie
to try and get to his family and that's
what Christmas is all about it's about
bringing your family together and yeah
so it's like Planes Trains and
Automobiles meets
meets Goonies Goonies meets Goonies yeah
because it's other world it's it's a
fantasy world
yeah it I'm in it right that's in that
way it's exactly in that way speaking of
fantasy worlds Sean I had to ask you
have you built this Lego Lord of the
Rings set the Rivendell one do you plan
on doing your lifetime if you haven't I
have spent months working on the
Legoland Rivendell set do you believe me
uh I sort
of I can't spend 10 seconds on Legos
first of all thr your fingers when you
snap them together if I was going to do
Lego would be the death star oh yeah
Death Star yeah that would be great he's
also a dad to daughters so did Legos
play a big part in their Liv sure they
did not my youngest One Love Like Love
Legos yeah trucks and stuff three
daughters yeah love it that's great um
things you would normally consider boy
boy yeah Mah my middle guy was a huge
Lego guy but Christopher I had a
question for you too you're being an
author yourself do you find anything in
scripts now that you value more or
appreciate more when you're reading
ahead you know um the thing about being
an actor when you're young is you think
it's all about you you're like what does
my character say I mean I know actors
that wouldn't read the script they would
just go from page to like see where they
are in the in the script and be like I'm
in it enough sure whatever what I've
learned by being an author and writing
books now is that the story is the thing
and that actors are there to serve a
specific part of the story so what is
your part in that story and it's made me
a really really generous I hope this
isn't arrogant thing to say but a
generous actor because not it's not
about me it's about the story that was
my experience of you yeah yeah thanks
man
um amazing I think that you were so
interested you so you were like I think
that's what you were doing is good for
your character because all these
different people com into your orbit and
you were just like whoa like what's this
new thing well dude it's true the shift
is like a book because you would come in
for a week so Sean ason had a whole week
and his his changed the literally the
temperature of the film and then
Elizabeth tabish would come and she
would change the tone and temperature of
the film Paris uh Paris Patel would come
in and he Chang John Billingsley like
dude you guys know him star trekers love
love the guy he he comes in and it was
his week to just kind of and so like
reading a book it was chapter by chapter
and all of a sudden Kevin's Journey
almost like The Iliad or the Odyssey
like you get to see these different
places as he finds his way back home and
also by the way just for your for your
for your for your viewers it's the Book
of Job set in the Multiverse and so
there's this really cool Faith element
about who you want to be in relationship
with um yeah you know is it the God is
it God or the devil because you got to
choose one I like too that you mentioned
it's like a book cuz the feeling of the
narration to me felt like that too which
really just brought me into it and Sean
my last question before I go um your
character of Gabriel he's always eating
a sandwich in this film do you get any
say to what type of Sandwich you're
eating on set here did you get a pick uh
they they had very good options for me
in fact sometimes they'll come and ask
and I'm like I don't know just something
you know like french bread no okay whole
wheat no I loved I loved the idea
because we were filming in this
Warehouse thing or this Mill and it was
a mill that had a lot of kind of tragic
history and also inspirational history
to it and we looked around and all the
uh the background performers were there
with a different you know a little fire
thing over here people were crashing
rocks over there and something about
eating kind of like tied it all together
somehow because it made it real and
natural and normal and not just um a
kind of plate that you're looking
against yeah it makes sense yeah Power
of the sandwich and eating yeah I love
it you know you nobody else seems to
have access to much food so to me it was
a little bit of like wait was is there
is this like is there a reason that this
is happening that this guy s has access
to food all the time yeah if you're a
smart viewer it's it it's literally a a
clue it's a clue there's there all these
Clues these Easter eggs throughout the
shift if you're a film if you're a
filmgoer not just because we're in it
you're going to love this movie again
it's huge in scope so you got to see it
in the theater and there are all these
little intricate details that sort of if
you watch it and again if you watch it
again and again every time becomes clear
you're like oh my gosh I didn't see that
the first time and then that's why he's
eating a sandwich I me it's really it's
that cool yeah and everyone check out
Sean and Christopher crushit in the
shift it's in theaters now thank you
guys so much for joining me and I hope
to talk to you in the future thank you